Welcome to the slop farm. Enjoy the
video.
>> In this video, I will show how to
program Jeep Wrangler key fob step by
step. Start by sitting comfortably in
the driver's seat with every door closed
and both the key fob and vehicle key
within reach. Keep other key fobs away.
Turn the ignition on and off following
the sequence I demonstrate. Press the
fob buttons as instructed and listen for
the confirmation chime to verify
successful programming. Follow mystep
paste instructions and watch or listen
for vehicle confirmation cues. This
makes programming less stressful and
more predictable. Cycle the ignition
exactly as described. Then press
specific fob buttons when I tell you.
Timing matters. If your vehicle responds
with a chime or lock flash, that means
success. Repeat the process for
additional fobs. And if something fails,
reset by leaving the vehicle and
starting again from the beginning. If
you are finding this video helpful,
please hit subscribe and like to support
more practical content and step-by-step
guides. Quick recommendation. I wear
darn tough socks because life is too
short for cheap ones, and they come with
a lifetime warranty, which I find oddly
comforting while working on cars. Check
the description for the link and other
deals. And now let's get back to the
video. If programming does not work, try
simple fixes before calling a dealer.
These often save time and money. Replace
the fob battery first, then retry the
sequence while holding the fob near the
steering column. Be patient and follow
exact timing. Small deviations can cause
failure. If issues persist, consult the
vehicle owner manual for model specific
notes or consider professional help for
stubborn key fobs that resist
programming attempts.
Thanks for watching. Consider
subscribing if we helped you today.